.
Pour parler de ces séries
éliminatoires exceptionnelles,
on reçoit l'entraîneur-chef
du Canadien de Montréal,
Dominique Ducharme.
Bonsoir, M. Ducharme.
- Bonsoir.
- Merci d'être là ce soir,
ça été une grosse journée, gros
bilan. On a eu chaud de ne pas
vous avoir ce soir.
- C'est une journée très
occupée, on aurait aimé ça l'a
repoussé plus longtemps, mais
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit
passer à travers chaque année,
mais d'être si près du but,
finalement, de s'incliner comme
ça, mais on est fié dans notre
groupe.
- Les parties ont aussi été très
fières durant toute la saison
d'insérer, j'ai dit d'entrée de
jeu, entraînant par intérim,
c'est une formalité, vous allez
être nommé entraîneur-chef d'ici
quelques jours, j'imagine.
- Je pense que Marc a répondu à
la question, il y a des dossiers
à régler, puis on va régler ça
dans les prochains jours, je
pense.
- Qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour
vous, parce que j'imagine que
c'est un rêve que vous caressez
depuis longtemps, d'être
l'entraîneur du Canadien de
Montréal.
- C'est certain, de pouvoir
accéder à la Ligue nationale,
c'est autre chose, de pouvoir
devenir entraîneur-chef dans la
Ligue nationale, c'est quelque
chose qui était un objectif pour
moi, c'est certain, mais de
pouvoir le faire avec les
Canadiens, c'est encore plus
spécial, en ayant grandi dans la
région où tout près, toujours
étant une partie du Canadien en
grandissant, oui, ça ajoute
encore quelque chose de spécial
à ça, c'est certain.
- C'est vraiment de ça que je
veux parler de ce soir, pas de
stratégie de le hockey, c'est
vraiment votre témoignage qui
m'intéresse, on se connaît
depuis longtemps, vous avez
entraîné à Joliette durant des
années, donc c'est vraiment
extraordinaire, les partisans
qui ont vibré comme jamais
depuis 93, à quel moment vous
avez commencé à savourer la
saison cette année?
- Je sais pas si j'ai vraiment
savouré, c'est certain que on
est tellement, ça se voit
tellement rapidement, on a une
saison qui était tellement
compliquée, plein d'embûches,
avec tout ce qui nous est
arrivé, c'est certain que notre
parcours en série, on l'a
apprécié, on n'en a profité à
chaque moment, mais je pense que
c'est un dans les prochains
jours et prochaines semaines
qu'on va être capables
d'apprécier où je suis rendu,
mais aussi apprécier ce qu'on a
fait puis ce qu'on a passé.
- Et déterminé à quelques
victoires à peine du précieux
trophée, ça apporte quoi comme
sentiment, comme sensation, est-
ce que c'est davantage de la
fierté ou de la déception de ne
pas avoir pu aller jusqu'au
bout.
- C'est un beau mélange des
deux, évidemment il y a de la
fierté parce qu'on a fait un
quart parcourt qui est assez
incroyable, ça été remplie
d'embûches, on a passé à travers
ces choses-là, mais d'être si
près, en même temps si loin,
c'est une déception de ne pas
être capable de mettre la main
sur ce trophée, il y a beaucoup
de gens qui disent que c'est le
profit le plus difficile à
gagner dans le sport
professionnel, et puis quand tu
arrives si près, de pas être
capable de le déterminer, ce
travail, c'est quelque chose qui
est en même temps décevant mais
qui nous motive à revenir l'an
prochain et encore se donner une
autre occasion d'y aller pour
ça.
- Crèvecoeur est à la fois une
motivation d'aller jusqu'au
bout, une prochaine fois. Vous
êtes arrivé dans un contexte
assez difficile au sein du
Canadien, vous avez pris la
place de Claude Julien alors
qu'il vous avait pris sous son
aile comme entraîneur adjoint,
est-ce que ça été difficile au
plan personnel cette année?
- Certainement, si j'avais écrit
un script dans lequel je
devenais entraîneur du Canadien,
ça aurait certainement pas été
dans ces conditions, de voir
Claude partir, de voir Kurk
parted partir même temps, parce
que j'ai appris à connaître, qui
m'ont beaucoup aidé, un gars
comme Claude qui a beaucoup
d'expérience, m'a fait confiance
beaucoup et il m'a pris sous son
aile aussi en quelque sorte. De
le voir partir de c'est
difficile, mais ça fait parti de
notre sport, donc évidemment
j'aurais aimé le faire sous
d'autres circonstances mais
c'est comme ça. Mais
aujourd'hui, on regarde en avant
et puis ça va être un peu plus
normal si on peut dire.
- C'est vrai que ça été beaucoup
de défis cette année avec la
pandémie et la période
d'isolement aussi en raison de
la COVID, ça a dû être
extrêmement difficile à
accepter, après avoir rêvé tant
d'années de se retrouver jusque-
là, d'être confiné comme ça
pendant deux semaines. Est-ce
que vous avez été découragé à ce
moment-là?
- Pas découragés, santé que j'ai
trouvé salon, 14 jours me
semblaient comme trois mois, par
contre, j'étais bien entouré
puis j'ai réussi avec le groupe
d'entraîneurs, avec les joueurs
à un peu garder le même
fonctionnement, donc j'étais en
communication avec les joueurs à
tous les jours mêmes si des fois
c'était pas tellement long, à
tous les jours, je parlais au
groupe d'entraîneurs ou une fois
par jour, Marc Bergevin m'a
donné un coup de fil aussi, les
joueurs, que ce soit entre les
matchs où après l'entraînement,
y en avait toujours un ou deux
qui m'appelaient pour avoir des
nouvelles, qui avaient que je
revienne que les choses comme
ça, donc autant j'avais hâte de
revenir, autant au moins j'ai pu
rester un petit peu connecté.
- Ça a dû être stressant quand
même d'avoir à gérer les à
distance de cette façon-là.
- Oui, puis de regarder les
matchs à la télé, ça faisait
trois ou quatre ans que j'avais
à regarder un match du Canadien
à la télé, d'être assis dans le
salon à regarder le match et de
ne pas avoir d'être capable
d'avoir un impact avec nos
joueurs ou de se sentir dans le
match, comme ça, c'était la
partie la plus difficile.
- Oregarde ensemble vos faits
d'armes en tant qu'entraîneur,
donc les dates importantes, vous
êtes allé à Halifax, vous avez
remporté la Coupe Memorial, la
médaille d'argent et médaille
d'or avec l'équipe Canada, cette
année finaliste de la Coupe
Stanley avec le Canadien, quand
on regarde ça, en 20 ans, vous
êtes devenu le premier québécois
développé par le Canadien de
Montréal à être nommé dans la
fonction d'entraîneur par
intérim, mais bon, ces mots vont
certainement enlever d'ici
quelque temps, comme le dit Marc
Bergevin tout à l'heure. Quelle
identité vous aimeriez avoir
pour l'équipe du Canadien de
Montréal, on parle beaucoup des
Québécois, de leur place au sein
de l'équipe, quel genre de qui
vous voulez avoir?
- C'est certain que de ce côté-
là, c'est des choses qui
allaient plus dans notre
département de recrutement, le
Maxi & Cie, je peux vous assurer
qu'il travail fort à trouver les
meilleurs joueurs possibles,
prendre en considération le fait
que nous sommes des Québécois,
on peut le voir avec
présentement, beaucoup de joies
qui sont signées et des
bourgeois qui peuvent nous aider
aussi, mais ce qu'on a vu comme
équipe, quand il parle
d'identité des de ces une équipe
comme on a vu à travers les
séries éliminatoires, qui
travaille Andril résilientes,
une équipe qui compétionner à
chaque moment, qui n'a pas peur
de faire face à des défis, ça
prend des joueurs de hockey
spéciaux, des personnes qui sont
capables de passer à travers ça,
puis le type de personne ou
d'équipe qu'on va avoir.
- Félicitations pour la saison
qui se termine peut-être pas
avec la côte; mais avec beaucoup
d'espoir, que c'est possible.
Dominic Fugère, merci beaucoup